so everybody loves Dr Doom and this
story is going to give us one of the
most powerful versions of Doctor Doom
ever actually a few different versions
of Dr new but this of course is Avengers
forever 2022. now this story is
technically kind of a spin-off story and
it originally started in Avengers volume
whatever from Jason Aaron Called Death
Hunters if you didn't see death hunters
or didn't see our video on it it's not
overly important you'll find a link in
the description if you're just curious
about it but the reality here is we
didn't really know a whole lot about
these guys we just kind of got them
teased to us a little bit but what's
basically going on at the moment right
now is you have What's called the
multiversal masters of evil I know it's
not a very good name but the idea behind
the masters of evil operating on this
scale is they're basically traveling
around the Multiverse and they're
killing the Avengers 1 million what's
the Avengers 1 million one of the things
Jason Aaron did when he took over
writing The Avengers Comics is he
basically told us before we got like
Captain America and Thor and Iron Man
and the Avengers that we have now you
had like Odin and the Phoenix force and
a handful of people who were operating
as Avengers in the very early days by
killing those guys off in each one of
these individual universes what it does
is it actually changes the progress of
that universe and the Avengers just
never really come into existence and
what it does is it allows the different
members of the Masters of evil to
conquer those worlds and then do
whatever it is they want to do with them
right just turn them into their own
playground and so what we end up doing
here is opening with the deaths of the
Avengers 1 million in this alternate
reality in Earth 818 and as this last
act what Odin does is he puts the
enchantment on his hammer but instead of
saying whosoever holds this Hammer if he
be worthy shall possess the power of
Thor that instead they'll possess the
all Vengeance the reason why is because
Odin has not had Thor yet so Thor
doesn't exist in this universe he's just
not there and so after this we basically
end up picking up with Ant-Man right
who's just kind of fleeing for his life
from these Venom bugs now one of the
things to know is that Ant-Man is not
supposed to be here doing this right
he's not supposed to be like digging
through relics and so on and we'll find
out out why that's the case here in a
minute but the big kicker the really big
moment that happens here is we end up
learning that this Ant-Man is not Hank
Pym and it's not Scott Lang it's Tony
Stark that in this alternate reality
Tony Stark never built the Iron Man
armor he's the one that built the
Ant-Man suit and so it's a really really
cool little bit of a turn here it's not
overly significant but it's kind of cool
and in fact instead of having like an AI
built into his Iron Man suit the way he
normally does he has what's called
shelled head which is basically this
little ant on top of a kind of Iron Man
helmet to a degree that he basically
uses to help him out whenever he needs
it and his character even goes so far as
to say that like he amused about the
idea of creating some kind of like a
technological suit But ultimately he
just didn't right so his life just went
in a different direction but one of the
cool things that goes on here and this
head that he's using is not actually an
Iron Man head instead what had gone on
is that in the North Pole he discovered
the head of a Celestial now this Falls
in line with what's going on with the
Avengers in the main Marvel Universe
right now in the sense that the Avengers
don't operate out of Avengers Mansion
anymore they actually operate out of an
old Celestial called the progenitor that
arrived on Earth and is actually where
all life on Earth came from but it's
called Avengers mountain and so Tony
Stark had basically discovered the head
of the progenitor Celestial that arrived
on Earth in the early days and led to
life and everything but in this
alternate universe using his ability to
shrink objects down he literally Shrunk
the head down and is just firing off
Celestial energy now the reality here is
that this Celestial energy is not
permanent it's not going to last forever
and so as he's been using it it's
basically just kind of been draining
down but in his exploration of the area
once he's able to fend off the attack he
ends up discovering the hammer of Odin
and when he initially tries to pick it
up of course he can't necessarily do it
but then he's able to actually lift it
effectively but having this artifact in
his possession is a pretty significant
moment because we end up finding out
that he's been collecting these things
and he even goes so far as to say like
we need to get out of here because the
War Machine machines are going to come
for us now under normal circumstances
war machine is just James Rhodes right
he's like the sidekick of Tony Stark who
has his own suit of armor which is
pretty false if I'm being honest with
you guys it's pretty dope in Marvel
Comics but in this alternate reality the
war machines are a police force and they
literally crack down with a level of
harshness almost never seen on anyone
who's here doing things they're not
supposed to be doing now the other
kicker about this and what makes this
kind of cool is the war machines are
actually based off of uh crossbones so
that's cool right like literary
crossbones being a Captain America
villain in the main Marvel Universe but
the uh face mask that looks like a skull
that's crossbones right now what ends up
happening in the midst of all this while
Tony Stark is trying to make his Escape
is he suddenly met by the arrival of
Ghost Rider Robbie Reyes now the way
that Robbie Reyes gets here comes off
the heels of the death hunter story in
The Avengers comic it's why I say you
don't have to read it it helps but the
only reason why he's here is because
there's this kind of multiversal police
force is called the death locks then it
basically just shown up on Earth and
they said Robbie Reyes some things are
popping off you got to come with us and
just snatched him away and this is where
they landed so that's the only big
takeaway from that comic in terms of how
it progresses into this but the thing to
understand is that Robbie Reyes is able
to face off against these war machines
quite readily I mean he's imbued with
the power of a ghost rider for those of
you guys who aren't really familiar with
that the power of a Ghost Rider is
basically the power of Mephisto on Earth
it's a ridiculous level of power so much
so that like a Ghost Rider has gone
toe-to-toe with like World breaker Hulk
and been fine right it's just it's nuts
how capable this guy is and there's even
been a Ghost Rider who's gone toe-to-toe
with Galactus right so it's just a crazy
level of power that these guys have it's
a plot device and how powerful a Ghost
Rider is is relative to whatever Story
the writer is writing but nonetheless
right these guys are able to basically
make their escape and then effectively
take off to the base of Tony Stark now
when they get there one of the things we
find out is the group is basically being
based by what's called a black skull
this is basically the red skull with a
Venom symbiote that's really all it is
it looks dope it looks ridiculously
amazing but once they get to the base of
Tony Stark we end up finding out that
what he's been doing is basically
digging up all these different relics of
what are what are believed to be
mythological levels of power right the
Phoenix Force Odin the first Iron Fist
the first black panther right the star
brand for those of you guys who don't
know about the star brand the star brand
is ridiculously op the idea behind the
star brand is that this is a person who
whenever they get the star brand the
level of power they have is comparable
to whoever they're defeating it is the
most plot device thing but basically if
a person with a star brand say for
example Tony Stark got the star brand
and like galatis comes to Earth and he
wants to consume it then the amount of
power Tony Stark would have in that
moment would be whatever power he needed
to defeat Galactus and then as soon as
Galactus Was Defeated he would basically
power back down again it's nuts but it's
really cool right I think what was it
Kevin Connor got it in uh Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers and
it was amazing it was it was so cool he
killed a beyonder but nonetheless right
I digress the thing about this is that
Tony Stark basically brings together
these different members of what R is
kind of uh you know Avengers team so to
speak or at least what passes for an
Avengers team you basically have a
cosmically infused Ben Grimm you've got
a Moon Knight you've got Vivian who in
the main Marvel universe is the daughter
of vision here it's heard still doing
that thing but kind of in a different
capacity and then you've got Simon
Williams Wonder Man Who for some reason
Marvel still sees as being relevant so
the thing here is that we kind of
transition away for a second and we pick
up on What's called the super flow now
for those of you guys who are curious
about this when it comes to the
Multiverse in Marvel Comics I always use
the example of a brick wall right each
brick in a wall represents a universe
the mortar in between that's the super
flow the space between universes and you
can navigate the superflow like
literally if you have a ship that's
capable the Fantastic Four can do it
right you could just go into the Super
flow and just ride it like an ocean and
take it to any any universe that you
want to get to there's different ways to
enter in and out of those universes but
you can do that the kicker to this is
that we actually end up picking up with
the daughters of Thor in the far-flung
future who are actually surfing the
super flow now these girls are
interesting they're kind of cool we
don't really know a lot about them and
we haven't really gotten a lot of
history on them and in fact we won't
even really get a whole lot here they're
going to be here for like a minute or
two and then leave but the overall gist
is that they're actually hunting for the
disembodied parts of cosmic Wolverine
right of like multiversalable Wolverine
who is imbued with the Phoenix Force
that's an old Thor story The Jason Aaron
wrote you'll find a link to the Jason
Aaron playlist in the description but
still right like picking up with Robbie
Reyes following his attempt to escape
the black skull and of course ultimately
being captured that he and death lock
are being tortured Robbie Reyes more so
than anything else because what the
black skull realizes is that Robbie
Reyes is not from this universe that
Robbie Reyes is from Earth 6 1 6 and
that if he can basically get information
from Robbie on how to access that
reality on how to find a way to conquer
it then it's all the better now what's
kind of going on behind the scenes is
that even if the black skull got that
information Doom Supreme who we'll see
here in a little bit wouldn't let him do
that anyway and the reason for that
isn't necessarily covered in this comic
but it is covered at some point what you
end up having is What's called the
Council of red and the Council of red
are basically a multiversal group of
mephistos quite literally and it's dope
it's so cool it's just like all these
mephistos from across the Multiverse
working together to try to find a way to
conquer the Multiverse together but Doom
Supreme and the Masters of evil kind of
in a roundabout way work for them but
one of the agreements that was struck
between the masters of evil specifically
when it came to Doom Supreme and the
Council of red is that they would not
touch Earth 616 the main Marvel Universe
until it was the only reality left and
then they would attack it now we don't
know exactly why that's the case
although we can largely assume that
because the main Marvel universe is
familiar with alternate realities they
would just go get help and that would
extend and prolong the conflict so by
getting rid of all the other universes
it basically nullifies all of that stuff
but with black skull basically
tormenting and torturing Robbie Reyes
Robbie's not forthcoming with
information as readily as black skull
would like and so what he starts doing
is basically screwing with his head that
he can't really harm him on a physical
level because of the level of power that
Robbie Reyes has right like black skull
cuts off an arm the arm grows back
because of the power of the Ghost Rider
and so what he ends up doing is actually
putting Robbie Reyes in a room with
seemingly a countless number of his own
versions right like different versions
of himself from across the Multiverse
and what he says in talking to him is he
says would you be surprised to know that
in most universes you don't even exist
and in the universe is where you do
exist you're incredibly significant you
becoming a ghost rider in the main
Marvel universe that's an anomaly it
hasn't happened anywhere else across the
Multiverse it's him basically playing
with him and toying with him but it's a
cool little bit of a revelation when it
comes to the role that Robbie Reyes has
in the greater Marvel Universe but when
he's put into this room or at least
enters into this room and sees all these
versions of himself what the black skull
says is I told every version of you in
this room the only way they can go back
home is if they kill every other version
of themself so either you're going to
have to just let yourself be killed by
these alternate reality versions of you
or you're going to have to do the one
thing that you don't want to do which
has become a cold-blooded died in the
wool killer because the reality is these
guys are all innocent they're all just
guys who are snatched up from their
realities and just put here right just
the wrong place at the wrong time while
being the wrong person and that's all it
really is but what ends up happening is
Robbie Reyes gets caught up in the
conflict as all these guys start
massacring each other and then in the
end he bends to the power of the Ghost
Rider and basically kills them all but
what it does is it breaks him on a
personal level it breaks him on
individual level and so that's when
Deathlok realizing what's going on here
when Robbie Reyes is thrown back into
the cell he tells him if you are taken
to be tortured by the black skull again
you will spill the beans on everything
it's unavoidable your mind is basically
broken it's only a matter of time before
you do you will tell him about the
Avengers you'll tell him about the
Fantastic Four the X-Men how to get in
and out of your different universes the
various protections the whole nine yards
you will basically become his Ally and
so where death lock is basically
treating the injuries of Robbie Reyes to
the best of his ability but also getting
frustrated by all the sheer number of
bugs that are around there we end up
finding out that it's actually Iron Man
who's basically staging an escape by
calling all these different little bugs
in and so on and so at this point once
the Escape is made the forces of Iron
Man alongside Robbie Reyes and his Ghost
Rider Powers actually launch an attack
against the black skull and his forces
and this is where things get kind of
murky because as this happens basically
the thing then Grim starts talking about
how like the infinity door is opening
and so on and so forth forth and where
his team sort of chimes in and says he's
been saying that for years it doesn't
really matter as you can tell from the
physical appearance of Ben Grimm he's
very crystalline in nature it looks like
he's imbued with Infinity Stones and the
reason why is because it seems like he
is the only thing we know about Ben
Grimm's history is that in the early
days in this reality when the black
skull took everything over that Ben
Graham who was already a member of the
Fantastic Four once the rest of the team
had been killed he basically traveled
into space to try to find a way to
defeat the black skull when he came back
he seemed to be possessed by the
Infinity Stones but as opposed to using
their power to like rewrite all of
history and so on he kind of seemed like
he was playing a much bigger role so if
anything he was just kind of buying
abiding time now is it just a way for
Jason Aaron to craft the story I mean
yeah right like anybody with Infinity
Stones can just snap their fingers and
rewrite the entirety of history in the
blink of an eye and there's no way the
black skull is powerful enough to
overcome an Infinity Gauntlet or anybody
wielding the infinity stone and so once
this whole conflict begins to kick off
Ben Grimm just kind of keeps on saying
the same thing right the door is opening
it is time Infinity calls Infinity must
be guarded the tower must stand all must
be assembled and so this larger role
that Ben Grimm seems to have been called
to play as a result of being possessed
or at least imbuing himself with the
Infinity Stones seems to be the means by
which or the vector whereby all the
different Avengers from across the
Multiverse are all basically banded
together right they all come together
for the singular cause and so he doesn't
really do a whole lot in terms of
conflict in action he does to a degree
but a lot of it comes by way of Moon
Knight and Viv for example who end up
going into the layer of the red scholar
or the black skull rather and like
trying to destroy the computer systems
and bring the entire like Kingdom quote
unquote everything else down and for the
most part it serves as purpose I mean
one of the big issues that they have
here is that where black skull is killed
in all of the conflict in the midst of
this whole kind of uh Nexus sort of
portal location where you have like all
these different gateways that lead to
like different places across the
Multiverse you actually end up having
these different iterations of The Red
Skull who come in right one of them
looks like classic Red Skull one of them
looks like Red Skull who's Captain
America during secret Empire one imbued
by the power of Carnage one of them
looks like Holocaust from back in the
1990s if you guys remember that
character from The Age of Apocalypse he
was dope like he was ridiculously
overpowered he was so cool and then
Marvel squandered him because they had
no idea what to do with this character
but the important thing here right the
important thing kind of getting back on
track with the daughters of Thor what
they end up doing when they're on Earth
is they realize the hammer of Thor has
reappeared here and it's literally just
hovering there almost as if it's waiting
and so what they kind of deduce is the
fact that the Hammers waiting on them
and so they end up attaching the hammer
to the front of their ship and when they
do the hammer takes off and it basically
leads them to Earth 818 right so this
reality where this whole conflict is
unfolding and the reason why is because
with the death of the black skull these
other versions of the Redstone all step
in and start launching an attack against
what passes for the Avengers under Tony
Stark's control and so as this massive
conflict unfolds the daughters of Thor
they show up again they don't really do
a whole lot here and it's kind of weird
to even see them here in the first place
they're here just long enough to kind of
help Stave off this fight and to sort of
turn things as far as the tide goes
towards the Avengers but at the end of
the day with the aid of Robbie Reyes the
power of the Ghost Rider what ends up
happening is these other red skulls are
all forced back into their alternate
realities and they're given a warning by
uh by Robbie Reyes when he says like let
whoever it is that you serve no I'm
coming for all of you and it's only a
matter of time before I get there and so
what we end up finding out is that as
far as the black skull goes he's not
actually killed instead what ended up
happening in a really cool twist as far
as Robbie Reyes went is that as the
Ghost Rider because his job is to judge
those who have committed misdeeds and
then to literally punish them based on
the actions they've committed that what
ends up happening is The Red Skull is
literally just kind of locked in what's
called Forever Penance where he's
effectively chained down without his
symbiote which has been taken by Robbie
Reyes and thrown into the trunk of his
hell charger and that as far as this
forever Penance goes the black skull is
just stuck there Locked In This Place
forever and he seemingly can't go
anywhere until somebody happens to come
along and basically free him but once
this entire conflict is over what ends
up happening is we basically pick up
with Moon Knight and with Viv who had
been yanked through the portal seemingly
and basically woke up in this area that
they know nothing about only to be met
by Peggy Carter Captain Britain along
with a Hawkeye and an Iron Man or
possibly a war machine in this alternate
reality albeit this war machine seems to
have the Insignia of Black Widow we
don't necessarily know because this is
an alternate reality and anything's
possible but what we end up doing is
jumping to the story of Doom Supreme and
this is why I say it's one of the
coolest stories that Marvel has going
for his character so Doom Supreme is
arguably the second most powerful
version of doctor Doom that we've ever
seen in Marvel Comics the most powerful
of course was Emperor Doom God kingdom
from Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers and Secret Wars stories which
was amazing the guy basically had the
power of the beyonders and could
seemingly do anything but this version
of Doom is exceedingly powerful one of
the things that happens though is that
with the masters of evil operating on a
multiversal level they invade Earth 91
which is an Earth where the Avengers are
basically made up of different versions
of man thing and so in this massive
fight that takes place seemingly all of
them are destroyed and then the process
has started to basically rewrite this
universe now what's funny about this is
that the masters of evil have some
pretty heavy-handed guys here Kip Thanos
is a really good example right I mean
there's some very powerful members who
are on this team basically Norman
Osborne the Green Goblin who has the
power of the Ghost Rider it's nuts what
these guys are capable of but when all
is said and done one of the things these
guys realize is Dr Doom has never
actually taken a world he's never
conquered a world for his own and when
they ask them the question of why that's
the case he simply just kind of discards
them considers them to be small and
doesn't really even give him a straight
answer but we get an answer and what
ends up happening is we basically have a
version of Dr Doom composed of man thing
right like a man thing version from an
alternate reality who became Doctor Doom
in that universe and what Doom Supreme
does is he actually tells him his story
and it's one of the coolest stories that
he gives right he says are you seeing it
yet the truth that has been carved
across this face do you see how deep the
scars run deeper than flesh than bone
than Immortal Soul deeper than any
health hit of sunless abyss of the
nether Realms the sinkholes of insanity
as old as the first screen their deaths
unplumbed by the most mystically
emboldened of Mortals into the black
infernos of which Doom descended doom
harrowed and doom rose again do you see
and so it's really awesome because
initially this version of man thing
ignores it right I mean he literally
just discards him was like I'm not
turning to your side I'm not joining
your cause or anything like that he's
hell-bent on maintaining himself and in
fact he even escapes and he attacks one
of the other versions of Doctor Doom
that come in now where he initially
thinks it's a doom bot which is pretty a
pretty accurate assumption Dr Doom
rarely ever deals with things on his own
he has doombots to do that for him and
in fact in a story called The Books of
Doom where you get the origin of Doctor
Doom you end up finding out at the end
the whole origin is told by a doombot
it's not actually Victor Von Doom who's
talking the entire time it's cool but
when man thing attacks one of these he
realizes it's not a doombot it's an
actual alternate reality version of
Doctor Doom and that's when Victor says
they are Dooms who once were where you
are now Dooms who hung on the cross
until they saw and now they will show
you the way and he says remove his
eyelids nail his head to the cross and
we shall continue it's pretty dark it's
pretty bleak I mean it's it's some rough
stuff and so once this is done and
they've literally got him pinned up Doom
Supreme asks he says do you know why I
take the dunes and he says do you see
can you tell how many faces I am wearing
and he says her name was Valeria a
Romani like me I loved her with the
all-consuming abandon of a child a love
so strong so very precious to me even
many years later that when I stripped
the living flesh from her bones I forged
with it an armor fueled by the power of
my own sacrifice and that's when man
thing Doom asked him like so you wear
her skin and the response of Doom
Supreme is not just hers the skins of
everyone that I've ever conquered I have
taken it I've hardened it and I've made
it my own he says I became the sorcerer
Supreme in that armor and in my universe
I conquered all that was literally he
destroyed and then literally took over
the whole of the universe Cosmic
entities galatis the whole nine yards he
overcame them all and he says and I
spent year torturing and defiling all
those who ever wronged me but as it
turns out given time anything can become
monotonous even our most joyful and
rewarding moments and he says it wasn't
enough that my enemies had suffered if I
was to know peace I realized I needed
them to have never existed that was when
I decided to murder my own prehistoric
Avengers right his Avengers 1 Million BC
the ones that came before all the
Avengers that existed in his own
universe and he says but my mystical
laborers had exhausted the enchantments
of my armor I would need to renew that
power with another sacrifice yet I found
I had nothing left to offer there was no
one else in existence whom I truly loved
except of course myself and so what he
started doing was jumping around from
one Universe to the next killing
alternate reality versions of himself
destroying these alternate reality
versions and seemingly absorbing all
their power into him and so in turn
that's bolstered him that's made him
more capable and has made him stronger
and it's made him one of the single most
powerful beings to ever exist across the
Multiverse in Marvel Comics and so he
says do you see now I confess I've begun
to wonder what it might feel like to be
seen without someone having to die in
the process and the response of man Doom
is please stop don't make me look
anymore and that's when man thing ends
up joining the side of Doom Supreme and
in fact he swears such a level of fealty
that Doom Supreme tells him cut out your
tongue and he does it right he literally
does it without question it's pretty
dark more so than that and what's so
crazy here is that this version of Doom
Supreme isn't seemingly the most
powerful one he's exceedingly capable
and is crazy what he can do but in this
kingdom in which he lives it's built on
the head of a being more powerful than
himself and that this being is actually
an entire Dr Doom Planet this guy has a
world unto himself with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
there is a part two so we will pick this
up next week thank you all for watching
and I will catch you all later
peace